okay here's the story son
once upon a time
it's been a tough couple of weeks for
john stamos following the death of his
longtime friend and former full house
co-star bob saggett but on sunday the 58
year old actor shared one sweet thing
that's cheering him up his
three-year-old son billy
john shared a lighthearted clip to his
insta story featuring a bedtime story
and some giggles alongside the caption
my heart okay here's the story son
once upon a time
come on man i'm trying to tell you a
story
quietly
once upon a time
he's very he's extremely shy at first
which i kind of like because he's not
like hello my baby i love my dolly but
once you get them going bill he does
bits he loves stunts he loves bits e.t
was with john and his wife caitlin
shortly after billy's third birthday and
the proud parents couldn't help but gush
over their little guy he's obsessed with
halloween and so it was a halloween
birthday party in april yeah he wanted
to be he wanted a ghost party and so he
dressed up like a ghost she just like a
ghost all the parents came dressed up as
ghosts the kids would go and i ghosted
the party and a few hours before john
shared that father-son video okay here's
the story son once upon a time
john posted this throwback snap with bob
posing in front of an art installation
called big love ball at their full house
co-star dave coulier's 2014 wedding
bob's my brother you know i've known him
since i was 18 years old it's pretty
amazing we become best friends but right
we literally
are brothers it's emotional and we love
each other and we've been friends all
these years
and we've been there for each other and
people have heard all this ad nauseam
but it's
it's honestly true i mean it's a it's an
extended family we've always loved each
other bob was found unresponsive in a
hotel room in orlando florida and
pronounced dead on january 9th just
hours after he finished a stand-up show
outside of jacksonville he was 65 years
old following his death a private
memorial service was held in los angeles
for the late tv star which was attended
by a number of his full house co-stars
including john and dave laurie lachlan
candace cameron beret and mary kate and
ashley olsen among others this is the
thing that touches me the most they're
friends of mine
they are
really friends of mine a source told et
that the service was quote very special
and that all of bob's favorite people
were together in one room that's a love
thing that's kind of what it is the late
comedian's wife kelly rizzo spoke at the
service as did john whose eulogy was
published by the los angeles times and
read in part quote i've spent days
refusing to let him go but now i'm
starting to realize i don't have to i
don't have to say goodbye because he's
never leaving my heart and i will
continue to thank him every day and let
him know what he means to me bob i will
never ever have another friend like you
you will always be my best friend
[Music]
you